[Music]
and I want to ask you about this last
time that that you were on the show nein
get it chances we're both huge Elvis
fans oh and we all have our different
era I love I love early rockabilly son
session Elvis but you you have a
different flavor air I love elbows
across the board you know the rebel
Elvis golden yeah me wrong but when it's
time for karaoke it's time for old Elvis
you like later-stage Elvis you like
younger bucks I'll give me that mid-70s
give me that Aloha special Elvis yeah
that was pretty doggone good I karaoke
Elvis that's why I always that's my
go-to I mean a lot of people Neil
Diamond I get it okay but the king is
the king for yeah and he delivers the
mail right King he gets that letter to
your door seems like there would be
people underneath the king that could
actually no no sir he's the king he
makes the whole service king he faxes
the documents no III love it so III but
I don't just do you know I just don't do
it Elvis because that's where you
karaoke you got a
it's entertainment It's Showtime so I
put a little karate Elvis in so you do
karate a little bit a little bit I like
to get up so while you're doing you're
doing the moves and the chops but you
guys I don't do real karate though like
I don't like you know I don't do real
karate which I know I totally know
I do old Elvis karate where he just kind
of planted himself yes he just anchored
himself and went oh he's a lot of grunts
oh there I go you know then I sit back
down winded yeah
[Applause]